in darkness assistance what we've looked
at is if you've got a whole set off
whoopsie-daisy I'm sorry if you've got a
whole set of dotto right you can
summarize this in a number of ways right
the first one we looked at summarizing
them all we called measures all now mean
mode and me what are they measures off
to my boy
it's kind of unusual typical sounding
phrase yes that's with a c and t yeah oh
very good
it is central yes the phrase was true
tendency yeah very good
where is the center tending towards
central tendency okay now a measure of
central tendency like this red line here
the mean they're really useful because
in a single number you guys ever get a
snapshot of the whole population and
that's really nice right so this is
really good because it's a single number
and that's really easy to read okay but
do you remember there was kind of a big
problem with measures of central
tendency and it came down the fact they
were a single number do you remember we
had look at three sets of data that all
had the same mean I think it was seven
do you remember this we looked at two
sets of data one of them would come like
this dollars you're sorry everywhere one
of them was on two groups two clusters
within the data one way below seven one
way by seven but they kind of I looked
at the middle I think there was one last
one I'll just draw 20 quickly where it
was like you know Eden comes in a
population and there's a whole bunch of
people down here and then there was one
guy here like 300 decimals and threw off
everyone okay so that it still averages
out and so maybe the central tendency
are nice but they have weaknesses so we
introduced a different kind of measure
to kind of counteract it they don't
remember excuse me it started with an S
it was about well we actually already
calculated 150 on this guy we called the
measures of spread right so it's like
how far is
Donna distribute it right these guys
like to do did you hire me though um
range was one of the measures of spread
but there were others they I remember
what the others were there were five
five other ones that sort of gave us
this number uh we had range we also have
this fib cord into quartile range which
then of course begs the question what
are quartiles again two more times up
there four equal sections
yeah very good ed scores that break up
all of your data are your population
into four equal sections
right so it's up quartiles are so then
we said okay you've got the the smallest
you've got the three quartiles the
middle of which we already know about is
the median and then you've got the
largest and we call this a five number
summary remember what we did with our
fat little booster we had a particular
way of showing it on a picture was that
cool yeah very good so you took each of
these right and you literally did
something like this for each of the five
boundaries okay and that's a cool now I
have a really good picture that shows me
where the cluster is etc and then from
this idea the more times we expanded it
some more detail remember what those
cause whenever yeah yes silence which is
not for but and there's percentiles
which is not 10 by 100 so you get the
idea
now let's just look at both of these
together right measures of central
tendency unlovely because they're very
secede a single number you capture the
whole thing the measure the spread of
better because they give you an idea of
like where are the numbers where the
scores distributed right and that's much
more informative wouldn't it be awesome
if you could take the benefit of central
tendency and the benefits are measured
spread and sort of combine them into a
single idea with both of these
advantages and we can we call the STG
headings
so standard deviation is a single number
for a whole population it's a single
number just like measures of central
tendency I see one a lot but within that
number with some fancy math I'm going to
show you shortly
it captures this idea how spread out is
data like is everyone together in one
little cluster or are they like all over
the shop okay
that's what measure of spread of about
it's really really practical by the way
if you want to use measures of spread
which are great you get five numbers
every time right now five numbers not
sound so bad on its own but if you were
oh I don't know for example a head
teacher of mathematics you are trying to
work out say 12 or 13 classes into
school and each one of them at five
dollars that's a lot of dollars to keep
in your head and it just gets confusing
much better if I can have every class as
one number and that tells me a lot more
information so I'm gonna do two things
here maybe three note to number one I'm
going to show you with this and you've
got in front of you I want to show you
what standard deviation is like the idea
and then secondly like one of the
wonderful things about this is this
actually despite being quite a whatsit
one despite being quite a fancy table we
have technology to work this out for us
the actual mathematics so it is quite
hard to do in quite type kitchen so I'm
gonna show you how to do we want to yes
so that's the two things and I'm
hopefully by doing this that'll show you
some examples of questions you can do so
pen at the ready are all highlighter or
something with other colors you can
write on top of this with what I want
you to notice is the measure of spread
here is about like getting everything in
order and then working out these
important numbers okay but another way I
can describe spread is to say how about
pink will do is to say well there's a
mean there's like one way of saying
where the center of the data is one way
of understanding how far these things
are spread out is to say for each of
these individual scores this is what I
want you to write in here drawing how
far whoops is each score from the
like these guys see this the further
they are away from the mean the more
this whole population is spread out does
that make sense so you can see some
scores are above the mains some scores
are below the mean that's the whole
point of me and you're gonna have every
time oh that's not much a whole bunch of
differences here we call this the
distance from the mean okay now once
you've got all of these filled in how am
I going to combine all of these together
and there's a whole bunch of different
ways you could do this I don't want to
suggest a way that I could combine all
of these differences into one so
standard deviation will be the actual
like what is the combination of all of
these things all of these differences
one like simple way of doing it is to
say okay well I'm just gonna average all
of us out I'm gonna average all of the
map take all of those differences and
say what is the average distance away
from the mean okay and you can imagine
if I had scores that were higher and
lower like say let's put a score all the
way up here say if you had a score like
that and you had some low scores let's
put a score down here for instance okay
the further this goes away really should
have picked a thicker brush the further
this goes away the more exaggerated
these distances are going to be you see
that so larger distances when you add
them all up you're going to get more
spread out okay but the way that the
standard deviation works is a little
more cover and here's what I just want
you to write down you can do it on that
piece of paper or if you can't fit it in
your book this is just a simple idea
what we do is we take all the distances
write all the distances from the mean
right what we do is we square them we
square each one individually okay so for
example you could say call them distance
one distance to distance three etc
according to however many scores you
have what we do is we square them we
square them and then we add them all up
so this gives you a really really big
number okay to get the standard
deviation out of this and I'm
simplifying a little bit but you don't
need to need know too much more than
this because your calculator will do the
heavy lifting for you because all these
numbers have been squared we then say
the standard deviation is the square
root of the sum of all of these numbers
divided by however any numbers you have
okay you can see this is like heaps of
mathematical work that's what we get
calculators to do this okay but all I
want you to get across is because it's
important later on when we talk about
things called lines of best fit there
are two things happening number one or
maybe three number one you're squaring
things the square of the distance is
what that is and then secondly you're
averaging out further you're taking the
square root because we want to undo that
squaring okay essentially that's what
standard deviation is and we use a
special symbol to indicate it which is a
lowercase Sigma that's the Greek letter
Sigma and then we say and for that whole
population okay as you'll discover a bit
later on when I talk about it in more
detail there are actually multiple kinds
of standard deviation but the one that
I'm going to talk about here is the
population one